[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
Arnaud Benedetti bonjour Arnaud merci
d'être avec nous rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire et
l'éditorialiste politique Michel daron
bonjour Michel merci d'être là on va
évidemment parler tout au long de ce
club de l'adoption de lo immigration
hier au Parlement un accord a donc été
trouvé entre la droite et la majorité
présidentielle sur un texte très proche
de celui du Sénat texte qu' a donc
décidé de voter le rassemblement
national esttive ça provoque une grave
crise une grave crise dans la majorité
oui feu d'artifice et gueule de bois
pour la macronie on en parle dans un
instant on en parle tout de suite au
début de ce club consacré à la loi
immigration et le Parlement a donc
adopté hier cette immigration accord
trouvé reprenant en grande partie le
texte du Sénat qu'il a donc adopté sans
encombre en début de soirée le vote
s'est révélé en revanche plus douleux du
côté de l'Assemblée nationale
adrienassemblée nationale a
adopté après 18 mois de coup de théâtre
autour d'un projet de loi inflammable le
vote à l'Assemblée nationale marque
l'adoption du texte géralde daranin se
félicite d'un texte fort obtenu d'après
lui sans les voix du RN la majorité a
été unie et a pu adopté des mesures
extrêmement fortes sur un texte qui
certes n'est pas parfait puisqu'il est
le fruit d'un accord mais je vrais
remarquer que c'est un texte très
difficile qui a été dopté 1493 un
constat que conteste le rassemblement
national ce soir si les députés du
rassemblement national n'avaient pas
voté pour cette loi cette loi ne passait
pas contrairement au mensonges de
Monsieur darbanin donc c'est les députés
du rassembl national qui ont pris leur
victoire idéologique et politique face
au députés le ministre de l'Intérieur a
tenté de rassurer l'a gauche de la
majorité régularisons ceux qui
travaillent ce sera sera 10000
régularisations en plus dès l'année
prochaine ce sera l'acquis de la
majorité de ce texte cela n'a pas
empêché au camp présidentiel d'être
fracturé lors du vote sur ces 251
députés près d'un/art ont voté contre ou
se sont abstenus le président de la
commission des lois Sacha aoulier a voté
contre et le président du groupe modem
s'est abstenu quant au band de gauche de
l'hémicycle il s'indigne contre un texte
qu'il juge d'extrême droite tout ce que
vous aviez tenu pour des ligne rougge a
été allègrement transgressé et que vous
vous rapprochez franchissez désormais
des bleu marine souhaitons-nous oui ou
non faire échec à une loi directement
inspirée du programme de Jean-Marie Le
Pen plusieurs gages de fermeté réclamés
par les LR ont été validés dans le texte
le président du parti Harti se réjouit
d'une victoire historique pour la droite
voilà journée et séquence d'ailleurs
riche Michel et Arnaud on va en parler
Michel qu'est-ce que vous retenez de
cette journée
d'hier une victoire parlementaire et une
défaite
politique c'est le cadre je pense voilà
que que que l'on peut poser pour pouvoir
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
le le le psychodrame depuis le la la
motion de rejet he de du texte en début
de semaine et tous les enchaînements à
la fois qui ont précipité ce qui est
déjà en gestation depuis quelques temps
c'est-à-dire la la fin de ce qu'on
appelle ce ce ce en même temps ce que
j'appelle en même tempisme et et et qui
est une manière de de tenter de de
d'installer un dépassement de la droite
et de la gauche alors qu'en réalité on
est de toute façon sur une tendance de
droitisation depuis déjà plusieurs
années et tout au long de de la semaine
on a assisté effectivement à chaque à
chaque coup de théâtre à à chaque scène
à chaque acte on a on a montré à chaque
fois comment cette majorité de plus en
plus difficile à maintenir en cohésion
comment la droite a joué sa survie
tirant plus ou moins c'est c'est marrant
du feu comment le le RN s'est positionné
en piégeant par en deux fois en deux
coups donc l'exécutif on a en votant la
motion de rejet puis en en déclarant
voter voter pour pour pour ce texte et
comment la gauche spectatrice on l'a
encore compris de de ce qui se passe
donc oui à la fin il y a un texte 1493
c'est quand même notable donc une
victoire parlementaire de l'exécutif du
gouvernement de Gérard armanin et dans
une certaine mesure de la première
ministre une défaite politique puisque
la majorité est en en grave fracture ce
matin ouais on va revenir vous nous avez
dit beaucoup de choses Michel vous vous
faites la même analyse AR victoire
parlementaire des fes Politi ah ben pour
le dire autrement arrivver à la même
conclusion c'est ce qui s'appelle une
victoire à la pirusse en effet ça été
adopté ça a été adopté il faut le
rappeler quand même grâce au voix du
rassemblement national quoi qu'on pense
et quoi qu'on dise monsieur Darman il
suffit de faire un simple calcul
d'ailleurs ça sera assez intéressant de
voir parce que le Président de la
République avait dit qu'il ne promul pas
le texte si ce texte était adopté avec
les voix du rassemblement national
va-t-il tenir sa promesse en tout cas
manifestement c'est la question que
posait votre interlocuteur monsieur fort
précédent tout à l'heure donc en effet
ça va être déjà un petit fil rouge de la
journée j'imagine en l'occurrence après
oui c'est une victoire j'allais dire
tactique et d'une certaine manière
idéologique de Marine Le Pen qui a fait
preuve je crois de d'une grande habileté
en deux temps comme vous l'avez rappelé
on mélant ses voix à la motion de rejet
dans un premier temps présenté par les
écologistes et par la gauche et ensuite
évidemment contre d'ailleurs l'avis en
tout cas les déclarations du président
du Rassemblement national monsieur
bardellaa a pris la décision de voter ce
texte et a piégé de fait d'une certaine
manière le président de la République et
sa majorité ensuite Jordan bnella le
matin même disait on s'abstiendra on v
ou on votera contre ben oui ben le
rassemblement national pas une seule
voix à à manqué hier soir pour voter et
adopter ce texte clairement quoi on
assiste on assiste à la lente
droitisation mais inéductaable
droitisation de du macronisme en effet
on est sorti d'une certaine façon des
ambiguïés du du en même temps mais ce
n'est pas sans conséquence politique sur
cette majorité ça va être d'autant plus
difficile que si vous voulez le
président de la République à l'Assemblée
nationale a une majorité relative ouais
par on a le sentiment que il a fracturé
tout le champ politique jusqu'à présent
il avait pas fracturé son camp et hier
soir il a fracturé son camp donc c'est
indéiablement un tournant je pense dans
ce quinqu là oua on va parler de la
crise au sein de la la macronie mais
peut-être un mot de Gérald haranin parce
qu'après la motion de rejet on a
beaucoup parlé de l'échec de Gérald
haranin qui était affaibli politiquement
or là le résultat c'est qu'il a fait
voter un texte qui est à droite ce qu'il
voulait à la base et 1493 est-ce qu'il a
échoué tant que ça bah là aussi c'est en
demi-tinte et peut-être en trompeleœil
le texte qui a été adopté n'était pas le
texte du Gouvernement c'est le texte
durci au Sénat euh retoqué comme on l'a
vu et reboutiqué dans le Conclave
d'urgence de la commission M paritaire
sous la la la dictée pratiquement et les
conditions de la droite donc il ne
s'agit pas du texte du Gouvernement donc
bien évidemment général maintenant il
fait son métier il vient devant les
micros et il dit il fait faire le
constat indéniable que la loi a été
votée que la loi a été voté 1493 c'était
son objectif euh et de ce point de
vue-là il peut considérer qu'il a
effectivement accompli son devoir mais
euh euh ça a révélé et ça montre à quel
point bien sûr euh de par aussi on en
parlera l'entêtement du chef de l'État
euh et bien que ce texte n'est pas celui
du gouvernement a fracturé sa majorité à
ce matin un ministre de démissionnaire
donc on ne sait pas si sa démission est
acceptée ou pas mais en tout cas c'est
quand même une manifestation sa
peut-être même pas s'il a présenté on va
en parler parce qu'éisabeth B sur France
Inter dit qu'Emmanuel Macron n'a jamais
reçu de lettre de démission de r Rous
oui alors c'est peut-être encore au lieu
de la matinée on va voir ça parce que
chacun joue avec ses éléments de langage
mais c'est quand même c'est quand même
une démarche de crise hier soir vous
aviez six ministres du pôle gauche de la
macronie qui là peut-être dans une
logique aussi peut-être de de je dirais
de de de dramatisation se sont se réunit
pour pour pour dire on envisage de
démissionner donc c'est les choses ne
vont pas pour le mieux ça c'est le moin
qu'on puisse dire et effectivement ce
quinquena maintenant est en marche mais
vers l'inconnu on va parler des des
fractures au sein de la macronie hein
puisque ce ce vote a provoqué des
fractures au sein de la majorité 37
députés Renaissance ne l'ont pas voté
soit ils ont voté contre soit ils se
sont abstenus et parmi ceux qui ont voté
contre le président de la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale sach
chaier pour en parler on va dans son
département de la Vienne on va à Poitier
où on retrouve Delphine Blanchard
journaliste à La Nouvelle République
bonjour Delphine merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous Delphine vous allez nous
parler de sa chaullier et de sa Drôme
d'pposition ouais ouais le 30 novembre
dernier nous avions accompagné pour la
Nouvelle République le député de la
Vienne lors d'une journée à l'Assemblée
nationale c'était une journée notamment
très importante en tant que président de
la commission des lois il débattait du
fameux article 3 sur les métiers en
tension et sach ier nous disait moi je
défends bec et ongle une loi immigration
qui est équilibrée et notamment il
venait de réhabiliter l'aide médicale
d'État le jeune député de 35 ans qui ne
cesse de monter on en parle très très
souvent est issu du parti socialiste
originaire du Poitou avocat de
profession et depuis hier soir donc dans
une position très très très
inconfortable le président de la
commission des lois il a été logiquement
désigné président de la commission mixte
paritaire la désormais fameuse CMP une
commission vous l'avez dit et redit pour
trouver un compromis et ce compromis là
il a été jugé bien trop à droite pour
Sacha aoulier est stampiller macroniste
de gauche alors ça ça veut dire quoi un
macroniste de gauche ben Sacha Houlier
en tout cas si on dit qu'il est de
gauche c'est parce que son début de
parcours politique se positionne là et
il s'est engagé en rejoignant le
Mouvement des Jeunes Socialistes en 2006
dans le centre-ville de Poitier dans les
archives de la Nouvelle République on
trouve le 18 mars mars de cette année-là
un sachaoulier au côté de Stéphane
séjourné défilant avec quelques 7000
manifestants contre le Contrat Première
Embauche le fameux CPE sa chaoulier est
alors lycéen et il se bat pour ses idées
et 10 ans plus tard au moment de la
candidature d'Emmanuel Macron il forme
en compagnie de Pierre Peron Stéphane
séjourné Guillaume chich Aurélien taché
et encore Gabriel Atal ce qu'on va
appeler la la bande de Poitier et il
sera même ensuite nommé délégué national
dans marche donc là la gauche commence à
être un petit peu loin mais hier soir
finalement il revient à ses amours
d'origine il a voté contre la loi il
aurait pu simplement s'abstenir non il a
voté contre radical le député fan de
foot a donc marqué contre son camp mais
à la sortie de l'hémicycle peu avant
minuit nous l'avons eu au téléphone et
il semblait droit dans ses bottes il
nous a dit il y a d'une part le
président de la CMP qui se devait de
faire respecter le processus des
institutions c'est ce que j'ai fait mais
il a le sachaoulier homme politique qui
a des convictions et mes convictions
elles sont humanistes et moi je ne
pouvais pas me retrouver dans cette
version du texte de loi
immigration promis a priori il n'y aura
pas de carton rouge pour Sacha aulier et
ses autres collègues le groupe
Renaissance leur a fait savoir nous
a-t-il confié hier soir qu'il n'y aurait
pas de sanction envers ceux qui ont voté
contre ou se sont abstenus Sacha Houlier
nous a dit notre groupe a bien compris
les raisons de nos doutes on verra à
terme si ces doutes créent pas pourtant
un mal à l'aise dans la majorité à faire
à suivre encore une foisphine merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces informations on
regarde la Une de La Nouvelle République
loi immigration crise politique majeure
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci
beaucoup den fin Blanchard et à très
vite Arnaud Benedetti pour reprendre
l'expression de de Delphine Blanchard on
a quand même Sacha aier qui est le
président de la commission des Lois du
Sénat donc il y a un poste qui est pas
n'importe lequel qui vote contre ce
texte est-ce que comme dit Delphine il a
marqué contre son
camp non il a voté en conscience
clairement en fonction de ses
convictions et c'estes son droit surtout
que monsieur sachaoulier n'a pour le
coup pas pris je vais dire entreêtre sa
son sa majorité et l'exécutif ça fait
déjà depuis plusieurs semaines voire
depuis plusieurs mois qu'il affiche un
certain nombre de principes sur ce sujet
de la loi immigration je rappelle qu'au
mois de septembre il avait Cigné une
tribune même avec des députés de la
nupes pour demander la régularisation
des métiers en en tension donc de ce
point de vue-là il est cohérent avec
lui-même après il l'explique très
bien votre votre consœur l'a dit bon il
a été président de la CMP il a fait
fonctionner la commission mixte
paritaire parce que il avait un pouvoir
institutionnel qui d'une certaine
manière l'obligerit à faire fonctionner
cette CMP après en tant que
parlementaire vous savez le mandat il
est représentatif il est pas impératif
en l'occurrence déjà et ensuite bah il a
fait jouer ses convictions mais
clairement ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'il y a une fracture au sein de
cette majorité et je comprends
évidemment que le groupe Renaissance ne
puisse pas prendre de sanctions
aujourd'hui contre ces députés
réfractaires vu l'état de ses forces à
l'Assemblée nationale François Hollande
avait des frondeurs mais il avait une
majorité absolue monsieur Macron
aujourd'hui a peut-être on verra par la
suite des frondeurs mais il a pas de
majorité absolue donc c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué ouais Michel on va on va
parler de de de ces Fract justeve Steve
il fait ses
devoirs
inér on va parler des des fractures au
sein de la macronie et de la crise
politique que ça a provoqué dans la
majorité ce qui s'appelle terminer
l'année en beauté oui c'était un feu
d'artifice he c'est ce que je vous
disais un feu d'artifice au Parlement
avant les fêtes de fin d'année 24 heures
sous très haute tension dans la majorité
présidentielle alors au fur et à mesure
de la journée d'hier le malaise a grandi
dans les troupes présidentielles à
mesure que la CMP la commission mixte
paritaire prog que les concessions
faites à la droite fuitaent dans la
presse ce texte de compromis est jugé
tellement droitisé que Marine Le Pen
annonce sur les coups de de 16 16h30 que
son groupe va voter pour le texte
réunion de crise à l'élysier faut-il ou
non retirer le texte la question est
clairement posée plusieurs ministres de
l'ail gauche menacent de démissionner si
le projet de loi a été voté on parle
notamment de Clément baun d'Aurélien
Rousseau de Patrice vergrid de Sylvie
retaillot de Rima abdulmac ou encore de
rol laascure pour désamorcer ce début de
front le gouvernement tente de montrer
bien que ce texte est aussi un peu pas
trop mais un peu un texte de gauche
juste avant le vote à l'Assemblée
nationale géralde Darmanin explique que
le projet va permettre de doubler le
nombre de régularisations des
travailleurs sans papiers soit entre 7
et 10000 titres supplémentaires chaque
année le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
promet aussi que le projet de loi
passera sans les voix du rassemblement
national
écoutez-le nous nous le disons ici
firement ce texte sera voté sans les
voix du rassemblement
national ce texte sera décomté sans les
national et contrairement à vous nous le
disons ici et contrairement à vous nous
le disons devant les Français et oui il
n'y aura pas de texte s'il n'y a pas de
majorité sans le rassemblement national
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
laanupes ça s'appelle le sens de
l'honneur est-ce qu'il a tenu sa
promesse oui et non plutôt non que oui
d'ailleurs on va voir le décompte final
il y a eu 573 votants pour
349 pour l'adoption avec une majorité
absolue à 268 si vous retirez les 88
voix du RN vous n'avez que 271 députés
pour ça n'est pas une majorité absolue
donc oui le texte est adopté sans la
nécessité des voie du RN mais oui aussi
si le groupe de Marine Le Pen avait voté
contre ce projet de loi et bien ça
passait pas ouis alors il y a eu des
défections dans la majorité
présidentielle si oui elles ont été un
peu moins dramatiques je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez vous n Le direz dans un
instant mais moins dramatiques que ce
que certains anticipé juste avant le
vote la majorité est quand même bien
éparpillée 20 députés Renaissance ont
voté contre 17 se sont abstenu côté
modem 30 ont voté pour 5 contre 15
abstentions côté horizon 28 députés ont
voté en faveur du texte deux députés ont
euh voté compre parmi les raisons de ce
vote compte dans la majorité
présidentielle on va voir euh les
raisons de l'ancienne ministre Nadia e
qui explique qu'un certain nombre de
lignes indépassables ont été franchies
et je ne peux pas y adhérer qui plusit
en mêlant ma voix à celle du
rassemblement national première
conséquence peut-être direct du vote
d'hier le ministre de la Santé Aurélien
Rousseau a présenté sa démission mais
peut-être qui s'est trompé d'adresse
écoutez ellisabeth borne ce matin sur
France interre dire un mot parce que
c'est quand même
incroyable on va l'écouter j'ai échanger
très tard dans la nuit avec le président
de la République qui n'a pas reçu la
démission d'Aurélien Rousseau donc c'est
un nom sujet moi j'ai échangé avec des
ministres qui sont concernés par les
dispositions de ce texte que j'ai
associé au maximum forcément il est
légitime que les ministres se posent des
questions pas question de supprimer
l'aide médicale d'État c'est aussi ce
que ce qui a déclaré Elisabeth borne on
sait que voilà le ministre de la Santé
aurait dû pu porter cette réforme à
partir du mois de janvier voilà on
essaie de de décrypter un peu ce qui se
passe dans les coulisses c'est assez
compliqué et de savoir où est la
lettre ission Michel est-ce que la
macronie est rentrée dans une crise
inédite bah elle rentre dans la crise au
fond elle assume ce que ce qui se dit
dans les rangs de la macronie vis-à-vis
du président de la République
c'est-à-dire où le questionnement sur
ses convictions son positionnement le
fait maintenant de plus en plus acté qu'
n'a pas grandchose à faire du Parlement
qui n'aime pas le Parlement qu'il voilà
qu' qu'il les traite pas bien de ce
point de vue-là tout est en train de
devenir maintenant assumer d'autant plus
qu'on on va aller de plus en plus quand
même vers la fin de du quinquena donc
vers la fin de la présidence d'Emmanuel
Macron et que quelque part chacun
reprend un peu maintenant ses je dirais
ses billes hein euh euh politiqu donc on
est dans un tournant ce qui s'est passé
ces derniers jours c'est c'est tournant
du oui on est dans dans un moment où au
fond les députés euh euh euh vous savez
quand vous parlez maintenant avec des
des des des des compagnons de route du
début de de de de de de la l'aventure
Macron euh c'est à peu près unanime hein
tous vous dit on est déçu on ne
reconnaît pas euh on peut plus lui
parler donc point de vue là c'est en
train de s'acter à travers ces ces
moments qui sont des moments de voilà de
de de je dirais de catartique qui
viennent dessiner et poser et
cristalliser maintenant la relation
entre les macronistes et le président de
la République et et ça va pas très
certainement aller en s'arrangeantant
ouais Arnaud c'est c'est un tournant
dans le ququen ou c'est la fin du
quinquena attendez la fin du quinquena
je vous je vous rappelle quand même que
ce na fait ça ne fait pas 2 ans que
Emmanuel Macron a été élu donc la
difficulté c'est que c'est comment il
fait maintenant parce que ça va être
long d'ici
2027 et qu on voit en effet l'État
aujourd'hui de cette majorité Emmanuel
Macron est confronté à un vrai sujet
c'est comment il peut relancer son
quinquen alors de ce point de vue là il
est un peu comme tous les présidents qui
ont été réélus hein le second mandat est
toujours compliqué hein d'ailleurs
depuis de Gaul on l'a vu mais tous
avaient si vous voulez un moment donné
essayé de relancer leur mandat comment
ils ont essayé de relancer leur mondat à
chaque fois par des référendums de Gaul
en 69 avec le résultat que l'on sait mit
Teran quand même en 92 avec Maastricht
parce qu'il avait senti que là on
touchait à quelque chose qui relevait du
nerf profond du pays Shirak aussi en
2005 alors avec là aussi le succès que
l'on sait est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
aura une initiative politique j'allais
dire digne de ses euh prédécesseurs
parce qu'il nous parle d'un grand
rendez-vous avec la nation pour le mois
de janvier le grand rendez-vous avec la
nation c'est quoi un grand débat très
franchement je suis pas sûr que ça
fonctionne euh le Conseil national de la
réfondation j'ai pas l'impression que ça
fonctionnne vraiment les rencontres de
Saint-Denis qui vont bientôt se dérouler
je vais dire dans un entre sooi
majoritaire je ne suis pas sûr que ça
fonctionne sous la 5e République les
initiatives politiques elles sont
fournies par la Constitution c'est quoi
c'est éventuellement la dissolution mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui une
dissolution poserait peut-être plus de
problèmes qu'elle ne permettrait de de
d'en résoudre et ensuite éventuellement
le référendum mais je ne vois pas si
vous voulez aujourd'hui d'autres armes
que les armes constitutionnelles pour
véritablement essayer de trancher le N
Gorden ça va être très compliqué quand
même de tenir comme cela jusqu'à 2000
2027 surtout après ce qui vient de se
passer parce que manifestement al sauf à
ce qu'il ait une alliance tout d'un coup
qui se noue avec sa droite c'est-à-dire
les LR mais je vois pas lesr
aujourd'hui se lancer aussi dans ce type
de d'aventure il est dans une impass
Emmanuel Macron il doit prendre la
parole ce soir il sera l'invité de cet
avou sur Fran 5 est-ce que cette prise
de parole peut être utile qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en
attendre soit il y a une décision forte
lisible concrète qui peut-être qui
pourrait être
le le le fait de de d'annoncer qu'il ne
promul pas ce texte qui finalement
l'enterre comme avait fait au fond
Chirac après le après le CPE sur la
fameuse formule de la
susmulgation on croit pas grand-chose
avec Emmanuel Macron on essaie de de
voir effectivement de comprendre ce qu'
peut ce qu' peut se dire et de d'essayer
de trouver des cohérences
dans la démarche un peu pulsionnelle que
que maintenant que que l'on connaît et
qu'on doit anticiper euh euh peut-être
ilut il va s'expliquer aussi sur la
philosophie de ce texte qui qui dans un
de ces dispositifs inclut les principes
de déchéance de nationalité on se
souvient qu'il avait exprimé son malêtre
son malaise philosophique avec cette
disposition en 2016 quand manuel Vals
tentait de la faire passer avec François
Hollande et là ça n'a pas l'air trop de
le gêner en tout cas pour l'instant donc
ce soir effectivement il
prend doit prendre la mesure de ce qui
s'est passé il est il a choisi aussi
voilà une émission qui est connu comme
étant une émission de de de de débat de
questionnement il y aura donc plusieurs
effectivement je dirais angles qui
seront abordés en même temps c'est c'est
un cadre absolument convivial on n'est
pas dans laallocution solennelle et
sévère c'est depuis l'Élysée visiblement
certes mais c'est mais c'est dans le cas
d'une émission qui voilà qui qui quand
même a sa marque et et son et son pu
public donc de ce point de vue là on
comprend qu' il y a aussi une envie de
de reparler à peut-être qu'il peut être
on va dire sa base naturelle sa base
électorale et sociologique naturelle
est-ce que finalement Arnaud cette
séquence ne fait que des gagnants sauf
la macronie
elle fait un gagnant à mon avis c'est
quand même le rassemblement national
parce que encore une fois il y a une
victoire tactique et une victoire
j'allais dire presque idéologique ça
pour le coup et ça manifestement je
crois que c'est le ce qu'on peut
retenirr lesr si parce que quand même le
le le texte qu'and le veille non le
texte qui a été adopté c'est le texte
DLR à 90 % 95 % c'est le texteel qu'il
avait été voté ici en première lecture
au Sénat donc ils ont
imposé leur cadrees et leur doctrine au
au au gouvernement oui la gauche est
défaite mais c'est une défaite relative
parce que de toute façon ils peuvent
j'allais dire se protéger par en
exciipant leurs principes moraux donc de
ce point de vue-là ils satisfont leur
leur électorat en effet il y a une
grande énigme c'est la majorité est-ce
que oui c'est quand même une défaite je
rejoins ce que disait Michel d'Armand
c'est-à-dire que ce ce cette réussite
très relative sur le plan parlementaire
débouche sur une défaite politique et
beaucoup d'incertitude il y avait déjà
beaucoup d'incertitude avant il y en a
encore plus aujourd'hui ouais qui va
laisser des traces c'est la fin du en
même temps au sein de la macronie c'est
le retour du clilvache gauche- droite au
sein de Macron ah oui mais qui a
toujours été présent en réalité c'était
n're jamais été autant affiré même temps
toujours été paravant en fait c'était
une manière en réalité de masquer la
droitisation installée depuis 2017 parce
que dès 2017 le le seul carburant
politique qui permet à Emmanuel Macron
de pouvoir être réélu ou d'imaginer être
réélu c'est la droite donc la
fracturation de la droite est un travail
qui a démarré depuis
2017 avec la la la la phraséologie on va
dire et la vitrine du du en même temps
du dépassement mais en réalité il y a
pas eu dépassement à chaque fois que
qu'il y a eu des je dirais des des des
des déçus ça toujours été le pôle gauche
de la de la macronie qui a toujours été
le laisser pour compte de de la
gouvernance et des décisions donc à
quelques exceptions près mais même
ellisabeth borne qui est qui est censé
émaner de du groupuscule territoire de
progrès qui est un des des des voilà des
des des des lieux de de la de la
macronie de gauche euh ne l'incarne ne
pas en aucune manière donc on on voit
bien qu'effectivement oui c'est c'est
c'est la fin de d'un système peut-être
ce soir sera-t-il officialisé ou
sera-t-il encore confirmé parce que on
sait queemmanuel Macron n'aime pas trop
être amené à à à reconnaître qu'il a
commis des erreurs à mot de conclusion
Arna oui aujourd'hui finalement Emmanuel
Macron est confronté à la grande
question de savoir comment il peut
relancer ou non son son quinquena alors
peut-être c'est peut-être aussi un
romaniment on peut imaginer que ça sera
une formule qui sera vrament adoptée il
y a la question aussi en effet du
maintien ou non de de Madame Bourne elle
peut exciper malgré tout le fait d'avoir
échapper à une mise en minorité sur ce
texte mais ça va être long encore une
fois on continue à parler de cette loi
immigration ça fait la une de vos
quotidiens régionaux ce
[Musique]
matin et à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux cette loi immigration adoptée
hier par le Parlement oui une loi
immigration voté à tout prix titre
charant lib qui s'est donc offert un
bouclage très tardif puisque le vote de
l'Assemblée nationale s'est terminé aux
alentours de 23h30 le journal revient
sur ses deux votes au Sénat puis à
l'Assemblée nationale et écrit que la
majorité présidentielle traverse une
fracture inédite après le soutien
apporté par le RN au texte immigration
de Gérald Darmanin d'autres quotidiens
on le voit reviennent sur cette adoption
un peu hors norme hier l'Est Républicain
La Dépêche du Midi ou encore les DNA
retour aussi sur le contenu de cette loi
oui à droite tout titre Courrier Picard
qui parle carrément de début de crise
politique on en parla il y a quelques
instants le journal revient sur les
dernières heures qui ont précédé le vote
à l'Assemblée nationale et se penche sur
le rôle que va jouer imemmanuel Macron
dans les prochaines heures le président
va s'exprimer sur la sur ce sur le sujet
ce sera en fin de journée il dispose
selon l'article 10 de la constitution de
15 jours pro pour promulguer cette loi
le renvoi devant la justice d'un
commissaire de police oui et 4 ans et
demi après la mort de Steve Maya
canisoan non le commissaire qui a
ordonné la dispersion lors de la fête de
la musique est renvoyé devant la justice
et la Une de presse auocéance ce matin
il sera jugé par le tribunal
correctionnel pour homicide homicide
involontaire son avocat qualifie cette
décision de scandaleuse et infondée
juridiquement la vie en mobilehome pour
des sinistrés c'est à la une de la voie
du Nord qui nous rappelle à quel point
les intempéries des dernières semaines
ont bouleversé la vie des sinistrés gros
planans sur ses habitants qui attendent
la remise en état de leur maison après
les inondations du mois dernier et qui
n'ont pas d'autre choix que d'installer
des mobilhomes devant leur domicile les
premières structures de ce type sont
arrivées lundi par convoi exceptionnel
dans la commune de blandck bon Steve
pour terminer on parle de choses
sérieuses de la bûche de la bûche de
Noël il y aura-t-il des bûches de la
bûche à Noël ce weekend c'est la
question que pose la montagne on parle
de bûche mais surtout de bûche pour se
chauffer au feu de bois l'année dernière
le marché du bois de chauffage avait
connu une grave pénurie cette année on
devrait pouvoir souffler écrit la
montagne les professionnels de la
filière bois ont anticipé ils ont
constitué des stocks suffisants merci
Steve la une de la revue politique et
parlementaire Arnaud le savant le
politique et le peupleen jeu du siècle
oui tout à fait avec une grande question
notamment après la crise covid comment
le politique peut dialoguer avec le
scientifique pour prendre des décisions
éclairées et rationnelles voilà merci
merci Arnaud merci Michel d'Armond
d'avoir été avec nous merci Steve
prochain rendez-vous sur notre antenne
c'est à 15h la séance de question
d'actualité au gouvernement et à 18h
Thomas H
et nous c'était la dernière de l'année
ouais déjàou passjà
pass et on se retrouve le 10 janvier
avec vous puisque ce sera un mercredi
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi et de
votre fidélité on vous souhaite
d'excellent fit de fin d'année à très
vite